>> John: I'M WILLING TO TRY
ANYTHING FROM WHITE CASTLE, NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
>> Sandra: DELICIOUS.
>> John: NOT COMING TO EL PASO,
THEY ARE COMING TO AMERICA AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT.
WE PUT THEM ON BUSSES WITH FOOD
AND GET TO THEIR DESTINATION AND
THAT WE CONTINUE TO TREAT PEOPLE
LIKE HUMAN BEINGS.
>> John: EL PASO'S DEMOCRATIC
MAYOR JUSTIFYING BUSSING
MIGRANTS TO NEW YORK CITY, HE
SAYS THEY DO NOT SEND THEM
ANYWHERE THEY DON'T WANT TO GO.
AND REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS ARE
UNDER FIRE FOR DOING THE SAME
THING.
A GLARING DOUBLE STANDARD HERE.
SENDING PEOPLE FROM HIS CITY TO
NEW YORK CITY, AND NOBODY IS
SAYING BOO ABOUT IT.
MEANTIME, DeSANTIS, ABBOTT, AND
DUCEY ARE GETTING RIPPED FOR THE
SAME THING.
>> BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
MOVED 1.7 MILLION ALIENS
THROUGHOUT THIS COUNTRY BY
AIRPLANE OR BUS OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS, 1.7 MILLION, AND
THAT'S A FRACTION WHAT THE
GOVERNOR IS DOING.
AND I JUST, THIS WEEKEND I READ
THE VICE PRESIDENT MADE A
COMMENT THAT THE GOVERNORS
ARE -- SHE'S ACCUSING THEM OF
DERELICTION OF DUTY.
THE BORDER CZAR ACCUSING
SOMEBODY ELSE OF DERELICTION OF
DUTY.
WE ARE GOING TO HIT ABOUT 2.3
ILLEGAL ENTRANCE THIS YEAR.
ADD 1.7 LAST YEAR, 4 MILLION
ILLEGAL ENCOUNTERS, ALMOST 5
MILLION AND SHE'S ACCUSING
SOMEBODY OF DERELICTION OF DUTY?
SHE HAS NOT RETURNED A PHONE
CALL FROM A CENTRAL AMERICAN
PRESIDENT, HAS NOT DONE A SINGLE
THING TO SLOW THE FLOW.
>> John: THE 19TH OF THE MONTH,
WE USUALLY GET THE PREVIOUS
NUMBERS.
DON'T KNOW WHAT AUGUST WAS.
>> IT WILL BE OVER 200,000.
ANOTHER RECORD.
>> John: 209,000 LAST AUGUST.
SOMETHING SIMILAR?
>> EXACTLY.
WHEN THE COUNTERS GO DOWN, THE
GOT-AWAYS GO UP.
UP TO 70% OF AGENTS OFF THE LINE
MEANS MORE GOT-AWAYS.
>> BACK TO THE IDEA OF PEOPLE
BEING BUSSED TO CITIES.
WHAT THE D.C MAY HAVE SAID.
>> WE ARE NOT A BORDER TOWN, WE
DON'T HAVE AN INFRASTRUCTURE TO
HANDLE THIS TYPE OF LEVEL OF
IMMIGRATION TO OUR CITY.
WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY.
WE ARE NOT TEXAS.
>> John: ANALYZE WHAT SHE SAID.
TEXAS DOES GET MONEY TO HANDLE
SOME PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER, BUT DOES TEXAS FROM THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HANDLE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ACROSS THE
BORDER?
>> NO, I'VE BEEN DOWN THERE
NUMEROUS TIMES.
THE SMALL TOWNS IN TEXAS ON THE
BORDER ARE OVERRUN.
SHE NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND, THEY
ARE GOING TO D.C. ANYWAY BECAUSE
IT'S A SANCTUARY CITY, LIKE D.C.
AND CHICAGO.
THEY CAN GET PROTECTED BY ICE,
GET A JOB AND DRIVER'S LICENSE,
NOW IT'S OUT IN THE OPEN SHE
WANTS TO PLAY POLITICS AND
ATTACK THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS
THAT ARE DOING IT.
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS ARE DOING
THE RIGHT THING.
THEY PUT THE ISSUE ON THE FRONT
PAGE.
MOST OF THE NETWORKS WERE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE BORDER CRISIS
BUT NOW THEY HAVE TO.
>> John: 9500 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
SENT TO THE DISTRICT, A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAN WHAT COMES ACROSS
THE BORDER EVERY DAY.
>> AND THE SOUTH OF TEXAS,
THAT'S TWO DAYS OF TRAFFIC.
>> John: DHS SECRETARY UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, JAY
JOHNSON SAID YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THEM AND SPREAD THEM BECAUSE THE
BORDER IS INUNDATED.
>> I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD DO.
8,000 A DAY INTO McALLEN,
HENRY'S DISTRICT IN LAREDO OR EL
PASO I'VE BEEN SAYING IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE.
WE NEED TO MOVE PEOPLE TO THE
INTERIOR.
>> John: HE SAYS IT'S SOMETHING
YOU HAVE TO DO, BUT DO IT
PROPERLY, AND GET NGOs AND
CHARITIES INVOLVED, NOT JUST PUT
PEOPLE ON A BUS.
>> I RESPECT JAY JOHNSON VERY
MUCH, I WORKED FOR HIM, I
DISAGREE WITH HIM ON THIS ISSUE.
WE CAN PUT REMAIN IN MEXICO BACK
IN PLACE AND WAIT FOR THE
HEARINGS LIKE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DID, AND THAT
WILL DRIVE THE NUMBERS DOWN,
LESS VULNERABLE PEOPLE PUT
THEMSELVES IN POSITION TO COME
HERE.
LESS MIGRANTS DIE.
OVER 1300 DEATHS ON U.S. SOIL,
OVER 100,000 FENTANYL OVERDOSE
DEATHS, 30% OF WOMEN GET RAPED.
WE HAVE ANOTHER OPTION.
REMAIN IN MEXICO SAVES LIVES.
LET THEM WAIT FOR THE HEARING,
IF THEY LOSE THEY ARE GONE.
SECURE BORDERS SAVES LIVES.
>> John: A WEEK AGO KAMALA
HARRIS SAID ON "MEET THE PRESS"
THE BORDER WAS SECURE.
LAST TUESDAY JOE MANCHIN SAID
THAT'S NOT TRUE, SHE'S WRONG.
LISTEN TO WHAT HENRY SAID
YESTERDAY.
>> THE BORDER IS NOT SECURE,
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
V.P., THIS, LOOK, WE GET
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ALONG THE
BORDER, FROM 6 TO 8,000 PEOPLE A
DAY.
THEY ARE RELEASING PEOPLE AND WE
CAN SEND YOU PICTURES AND VIDEOS
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN DEL RIO
AND THE VALLEY, EL PASO AND
OTHER PLACES.
PEOPLE ARE COMING IN.
L>> John: PEOPLE ARE COMING IN,
HE SAYS THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
WRONG.
THIS IS KIND OF LIKE HAVING A
DRINKING PROBLEM.
UNTIL THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ADMITS THAT THERE'S A DRINKING
PROBLEM, SORRY, A BORDER
PROBLEM, IMMIGRATION PROBLEM,
WILL THEY BE ABLE TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT?
>> THEY DON'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
AND HENRY HAS BEEN A
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE BORDER
STATES FOR A LONG TIME.
HE KNOWS THE BORDER, HE LIVES AT
THE BORDER, HE'S SPEAKING THE
TRUTH.
THIS ADMINISTRATION DON'T WANT
TO FIX IT.
THEY HAVE NOT DONE ONE THING TO
SLOW THE FLOW.
EVERYTHING IS ABOUT RELEASING,
PROCESSING QUICKER, RELEASING
QUICKER AND NO FOLLOW-UP.
AND 90% GET THE ORDER TO REMOVE,
ICE IS NOT EVEN LOOKING FOR
THEM.
>> John: PEOPLE ARE FINALLY
STARTING TO TA